more than three million people have
signed up to storm area 51 in September
to see them aliens there's probably not
any men in black working with
extraterrestrials in the Nevada desert
what's actually going on at area 51 is
even cooler the Air Force originally
bought area 51 to test the famous u2
reconnaissance plane often the source of
UFO sightings during the Cold War it was
later used to develop America's first
operational stealth aircraft the f-117
nighthawk his secretive Southwest
training ranges have grown significantly
over the years and today they're working
on bleeding edge aircraft tech for the
US military like the new b21 stealth
bomber and the x-37b space plane these
ranges also help to develop the rq-170
stealth drone used to find bin Laden and
the rq-180 it's successor of which no
pictures exist area 51 in its cousins
are also crucial to testing a whole host
of revolutionary unmanned combat drones
to work with our current fighters the
f-35 in f-22 so when the motherships do
show up and Bill Pullman leads us into
battle humanity's best chance of victory
lies in the aircraft being tested at
area 51 today what's the coolest thing
the Air Force is working on today let us
know in our poll also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research of
videos from a yacht